you have a reputation in the business of
being one of those people that will
always take a selfie yes you will you
never say no to a selfie
and-and-and-and you're just that way
which i think is admirable thank you
yeah except for that word selfie I
really have always bristled at the word
and what I find really annoying in
particular I'll always take a photo with
anybody it doesn't matter and I
certainly won't judge them in the moment
but there's the thing now where people
will just ask for a photo and they'll
take it normal instead of the self
facing camera and they'll say it's a
selfie I'm like that's not a selfie
that's a photo that is a photo yeah now
we're taking a photo it's not a selfie
and then you know what you sound like a
dick now I take back all that stuff I
had earlier right have a smoke
[Laughter]
so yes okay but you're right right you
know what I have found is that so it's
one thing yeah they have to you have to
turn it around and you got to get in
there and you have to have the selfie
that is that is a selfie yes what I have
found and this happens a lot with I
would say people over 60 is that they'll
say to me oh you're the strange fellow
and I'll go yes yes and then they'll say
I want a picture of you and they don't
even want to be in it
yeah they stay right there and I go oh
and then I say to them that's no good
you could have just gotten that off the
internet you're like no it came out yes
I'm like no you have to be in a truther
like why would I be in it I'm not famous
I never take a photo with you yeah Aaron
what's the other one I love is when
three two people come up and they or
three people come up and say hey Conan
can we go selfies I'm like sure take it
with one taker with the other and then I
say to the third one would you like one
and they go I'm good it would just take
a second I'd rather not yeah you know
but you are right you're very popular
you you have there's a meme of you on it
do you know this someone saw you yeah I
guess out riding a scooter yes this is
in this was in Austin Texas there's a
film festival I go to every year called
Fantastic Fest in Austin says genre and
horror film festival it's great and
they're you know they're these these
uber driven ones I think ones called
bird or something there's all these
different scooter you can like sign up
for the app and bird I think there was
lime I don't know if that stole right
yeah exactly so I think this is actually
a lime scooter and I'd never done it so
I like downloaded the app just because I
want and there was one sitting there at
the theater I thought I'll just ride
this thing so I got on it and rode and I
had a cigarette my mouth not anymore
and and then and just kind of like was
being silly riding this thing and then
my friend Robert Cargill actually took
that photo immediately put it on Twitter
and within five minutes there were memes
yeah and it has continued it's becomes a
whole ongoing meme of you on a scooter
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because it became this meme some people
have done really creative things with it
I like this one there's a lot of them
out there you're not leading the pack
but you're in the middle you're doing
pretty well I'm hanging out yeah you're
doing really well there